[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois-xavier bellamy bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
députation membres à des républicains en
ensemble pendant 20 minutes et on va
commencer par cette affaire des écoutes
un l'hebdomadaire le point qui révèle
que le parquet national financiers a mis
des avocats sur écoute pour trouver la
taupe ayant informé nicolas sarkozy
qu'il était lui-même sur écoute en 2014
est ce que pour vous nicolas sarkozy a
fait l'objet d'une procédure déloyale
cette affaire est d'une immense gravité
et au delà de cette affaire d'ailleurs
elle est le symptôme d'une dérive très
inquiétante de la justice et surtout
d'une instrumentalisation de la justice
par les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé au fond on le voit bien il y à
ici une procédure qui menace le coeur de
l'état de droit c'est à dire la capacité
d'un citoyen à se défendre
bien sûr il est nécessaire que chacun
puisse être traitée conformément à la
loi
et lorsqu'une procédure judiciaire a
lieu il faut qu'elle aille jusqu'à son
terme personne n'est au dessus des lois
mais à l'intérieur de notre système
judiciaire il y à un principe
fondamental qui est la capacité de
chaque citoyen à organiser sa défense
ceci remonte déjà bien bien avant même
la république et c'est au coeur de notre
tradition politique et judiciaire
et je crois que là nous voyons que
l'essentiel est en cause quand des
avocats de nombreux avocats sont placées
sous surveillance géolocaliser que leurs
relevés téléphoniques sont épluchés sans
aucune espèce de connexion apparente
avec le dossier sans qu'aucune
infraction ne puisse être relevé à leur
encontre
quand par ailleurs cette procédure est
entièrement dissimulé et heureusement
que vos confrères du point nous ont
permis de la connaître car normalement
une procédure judiciaire devient public
à un certain point pour pouvoir
précisément servir à charge ou à
décharge
ici la procédure peut-être parce
qu'elles contribuaient à montrer que
nicolas sarkozy n'était pas coupable des
faits qui lui étaient reprochés n'est
jamais apparu dans dans dans aucune
espèce de processus officiel public et
donc là il ya vraiment des faits d'une
très grande gravité
si on rapproche ça de ce conte
ce qu'on vient d'apprendre par ailleurs
ou en tous les cas des propos qui ont
été tenus récemment par eliane houlette
qui était à la tête du parquet national
financiers concernant les pressions
qu'elle a subies de la part de
l'exécutif dans la procédure menée à
l'occasion de la sphère fillon en pleine
campagne présidentielle
oui on a de quoi s'inquiéter de façon
très forte pour l'état de droit en
france
et justement puisque vous parlez d'état
de droit nicolas sarkozy a réagi à
serrer ses révélations du point
et justement il demande le respect de
l'état de droit vous aussi vous dites en
france il ya un problème avec l'état
demande bien sûr en tous les cas il ya
ici un sujet d'inquiétude majeur et je
crois qu'il est absolument fondamental
que ces dysfonctionnements très grave
soit l'objet d'une investigation résolu
indépendante qui permettent de faire la
lumière totale sur ces processus
judiciaire sur ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
sur les contrôles qui n'ont pas été
appliquées de manière clairement les
responsables soient sanctionnés parce
qu'il y a des responsables de ces
dérives et qu'ensuite on se donne les
moyens de ne plus tomber dans de tels
travers à l'affût des responsables qui
peuvent être politique est-ce qu'il ya
clairement des pressions politiques des
pressions de l'exécutif sur la justice
en france mais justement ça fait partie
de l'état de droit de ne pas juger avant
de connaître la totalité des faits mais
manifestement il y a en tous les cas des
dérives qui ont eu lieu dans sept dans
cette enquête sur nicolas sarkozy il y à
des pressions qui sont rapportés par une
magistrate de premier ordre devant une
commission parlementaire sur le cas de
françois fillon dans ces deux domaines
il faut qu'une investigation poussée
permettent de donner aux français
toute la connaissance de ce qui s'est
vraiment passé de sanctionner tous les
to les infractions qui ont pu être
commises et encore une fois de garantir
que cela ne se reproduise il faut aussi
supprimer ce parc national financiers
pour vous ce qui est tout à fait
frappant c'est que souvenons nous que ce
parc national financier avait été créée
par françois hollande à l'issue de la
sphère cahuzac comme un moyen de
garantir aux français que la lutte
contre la corruption serait désormais
résolus et transparentes
or on le voit cet outil en fête a été
utilisée par le pouvoir qu'il avait créé
non pas au service des français mais au
service semble-t-il de ses propres
intérêts de son propre agenda politique
je ne sais pas s'il faut le dissoudre
mais en tous les cas il y à manille
justement des des verrous a créé pour
garantir la transparence nécessaire et
j'ajoute un dernier mot aujourd'hui nous
vivons dans notre pays une situation de
très grande fragilité de la justice on
l'a vu d'ailleurs pendant la crise du
coronavirus où la justice est le service
public qui a été sans doute le plus
interrompu le plus directement affectés
par cette crise pourquoi parce que la
justice française est depuis très
longtemps sous financée elle est l'une
des plus pauvres en europe si on la
rapporte à la dépense par par citoyen et
les justiciables français les citoyens
français le savent bien
pour obtenir une décision de justice il
faut souvent attendre très longtemps il
faut passer par un parcours du
combattant il faut faire face à la
paupérisation de l'institution
judiciaire et et c'est une source de
frustration très grande notamment pour
beaucoup de français quand ils sont
victimes d'une infraction d'une violence
et quand en réalité ils voient que cette
infraction n'est jamais sanctionnés
selon mal de l'âge il est absolument
tragique de voir que la justice est dans
un tel état de fragilité pour les
français ordinaires et qu' elle se
trouve l'occasion d'une
instrumentalisation si massive
quand elle les mises à la disposition du
pouvoir ou quand elle est détournée à la
disposition du pouvoir
je pense qu'on a un vrai sujet sur la
justice dans notre pays on n'en parle
pas assez
mais il faut absolument et ça doit faire
partie d'une réforme de l'état de droit
dans notre pays il faut repenser la
justice il faut la refinancer
il faut d'une manière générale redonner
aux français confiance en la justice
et ça c'est un travail de long terme qui
nous attend elle est l'autre sujet c'est
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur qui était auditionné au
sénat hier par la mission d'information
sur les moyens d'action et les méthodes
d'intervention de la police et de la
gendarmerie est ce qu'il ya un problème
avec la doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
en france il ya un problème avec l'ordre
public en france et c'est là dessus que
christophe castaner ne rend pas assez
compte il y a un problème manifeste avec
l'ordre public quand des militants
peuvent venir faire une action de
militantisme sur les grilles même du
ministère de l'intérieur à 50 mètres de
l'elysée sans être apparemment inquiéter
via un complexe de maintien de l'ordre
quand oui dans la dernière manifestation
qui a eu lieu sur l'esplanade des
invalides
id un gaz toxique a été utilisés contre
les crs les policiers les gendarmes
chargés d'assurer le maintien de l'ordre
et moi je trouve révoltant je vous le
dis comme je le pense je trouve
révoltant qu'on ne parle de la police
aujourd'hui que pour dénoncer des
violences policières
il ya quelques jours au moment de crs
ont été violemment pris à partie dans un
bar et se sont abstenus de répondre et
se sont laissé frapper de peur d'être
considérés comme de potentiels coupables
il ya quelques jours un policier son
épouse rentrant de leur service ont été
agressés à lyon et le policier est
actuellement encore hospitalisés au fond
je crois que on ne mesure pas assez la
violence que vivent au quotidien les
policiers dont ils sont les victimes et
non pas les coupables
lorsque lorsque les policiers commettent
des dérives
il faut évidemment que ces dérives
soient sanctionnés il faut qu'elles le
soient d'autant plus que la force
publique qui leur est confiée
les engage à une responsabilité et
singulière mais comment se fait-il que
on parle sans cesse de quelques cas de
dérive et que jamais on ne parle que
jamais on insiste que jamais on ne met
en lumière ce que vivent aujourd'hui les
policiers les gendarmes ferment moi je
suis je suis je voudrais dire je suis
impressionné que des hommes et des
femmes choisissent d'assumer de
continuer d'assumer leurs missions pour
notre sécurité pour notre paix alors
même qu'ils sont l'objet d'une suspicion
permanente et qu'ils doivent faire face
quotidiennement à une violence aussi un
danger encore 40 et pas de penser quand
vous dites c'est un problème avec
l'ordre public est ce que clairement ça
veut dire qu'il ya trop de laxisme
ça veut dire que il est apte absolument
anormal que en place les policiers les
gendarmes dans une telle situation de
faiblesse
d'abord par effectivement des doctrines
d'emploi qui semble inadapté et on le
voit bien quand le ministère de
l'intérieur semble lui-même incapable de
maintenir l'ordre aux abords immédiats
de l'elysée mais mais aussi par ses
discours qui ne cesse de se propager il
faut prendre conscience de la réalité de
l'impact de ses discours quand nous
passons notre temps sur les plateaux de
télévision
radio dans les médias dans le monde
politique quand nous passons notre temps
à mettre en doute et en cause des
violences policières
en réalité nous créons chez ceux qui
veulent défier la police et la
gendarmerie
un sentiment d'impunité un sentiment de
toute puissance
un jeune de 16 ans il y as je crois 48
heures pris en flagrant délit de rodéos
sauvages sans casque se jette avec sa
moto sur l'agent de police qui venaient
à pied de peur de créer un accident qui
venait à pied pour l'arrêter et le
percute au visage avec la roue avant de
sa moto est ce qu'aujourd'hui le vrai
problème dans notre pays c'est les
violences policières
désarmons la police comme le propose
monsieur mélenchon et on va voir à quoi
ressemble la violence et quand la police
et des armées
quand elle l'est aujourd'hui non pas
seulement matériellement mais aussi
moralement j'allais dire alors on voit
ce que c'est que la violence hier
avant-hier pardon à vaulx en velin
un enfant de 5 ans est percuté par un
jeune en motocross il est actuellement
dans le coma je crois en tous les cas
son pronostic vital est engagé
je me souviens qu'il ya un mois quand un
jeune s'est tué à argenteuil en
percutant un poteau électrique il ya eu
des manifestations à sa mémoire
il faisait un motocross sans casque il y
a eu des manifestations en sa mémoire
qui parlent aujourd'hui de cet enfant de
5 ans percuté dans un rodéo qui en parle
je crois qu'il ya une asymétrie dans le
rapport à la violence dans notre pays
qui est extrêmement grave parce que
quand on passe notre temps à suspecter
la violence dans l'autorité on désarme
l'autorité et on voit ressurgir la
véritable un mot au delà des violences
policières sur les tensions
dans le pays est ce que la france est en
train de prendre le chemin des
états-unis est ce que l'universalisme
républicain est en train de laisser la
place au communautarisme
il ne le faut pas absolument pas nous ne
sommes pas les états unis et cette
américanisation de nos débats est
absolument stupéfiante
elle est d'ailleurs encore une fois je
le dis je crois le lot d'un microcosme
je ne vois pas qu'aujourd'hui des
centaines de milliers de personnes se
soient mobilisés sur les places et dans
les rues pour demander qu on déboulonne
les statuts c'est le fait d'un tout
petit nombre de gens qui sont engagés
dans un conflit idéologique non pas avec
les travers et les erreurs de l'histoire
parce que tout le monde reconnaît les
travers et les erreurs de l'histoire
mais qui sont engagés dans un conflit
idéologique avec notre histoire avec
notre culture avec notre civilisation
quand on s'attaque à la statue de
colbert devant l'assemblée nationale
pardon mais quelle caricature absurde
que celle qui conduit notre génération a
jugé le passé avec une telle facilité à
l'aune de nos propres convictions et de
nos propres opinions selon willy bien
sûr dans toutes les étapes de l'histoire
dans toutes les grandes personnalités de
l'histoire de notre histoire comme de
toute histoire
il y a eu des travers des défauts il y
avait des prises de conscience à vivre
et des erreurs à corriger c'est une
évidence absolue
ça n'empêche pas de regarder la grandeur
dans ceux qui nous ont précédés et dans
l'héritage qu'il nous laisse et ça nous
oblige à encore plus d'humilité parce
que quand nous voyons que colbert dont
nous savons le génie avait pu faire
erreur sur la question aussi majeure
concernant la dignité humaine que
l'école esclavage alors plutôt que de
juger colbert nous devrions nous
inquiéter de nous mêmes en nous
demandant si nous sommes nous-mêmes
immunisé contre toute erreur contre tout
défaut de jugement ce n'est que par un
orgueil absolue que nous en venons à
condamner avec tant de condescendance le
passé sans recevoir ce qu'il a de
meilleur à nous offrir
et tenter de l'améliorer de ce que nous
pouvons apporter on va parler de 7 après
crise emmanuel macron qui consultent les
différents partis qui consultent aussi
les anciens présidents de la république
qu'est ce que vous attendez vaude
emmanuel macron est ce que vous attendez
un tournant sur le fond de sa politique
ou un changement dans sa manière de
régit le pays peut-être derrière cette
mise en scène des consultations en tous
sens on a surtout besoin de finir avec
la communication et de rentrer dans une
action c'est que de la mise en scène y a
pas de réelle écoute de l'opposition non
je ne dis même pas cela mais je voulais
ce qui ce qui compte ce n'est pas
d'abord qu'on nous parle sans cesse de
ses consultations ce qui compte c'est ce
qui va en sortir et ce qui compte c'est
qu'à l'action va être menée aujourd'hui
et de ce point de vue là on a simplement
besoin d'un cadre clair peut-être moins
de moins de paroles et plus c'est plus
d'actes je crois que c'est ce qui
pourrait faire du bien la france
aujourd'hui
l'autre sujet c'est suivre la
décentralisation emmanuel macron qui a
ouvert la porte à cette nouvelle étape
de la décentralisation gérard larcher
qui va d'ailleurs faire des propositions
la semaine prochaine est ce que pour
vous une décentralisation une réelle
décentralisation est possible dans un
pays qui attend tant de l'état comme on
l'a vu pendant cette crise mais l'état
joue et continuera de jouer dans notre
pays un rôle fondamental en revanche oui
il est absolument clair que nous devons
retrouver avec le grand principe de
subsidiarité le sens de la décision
locale et de la responsabilité locale et
ça suppose de faire un choix enfin clair
dans le mille feuille territorial qu'est
la france j'ai vécu comme élu local
pendant pendant pendant de longues
années quand vous êtes élu dans une
ville vous avez au dessus de vous
désormais l'intercommunalité
parfois la métropole le département la
région l'état ajoutez à cela quelques
établissements publics ou organismes
supplémentaires et vous avez toutes les
conditions pour une paralysie de la
décision publique à la fois une
multiplication des dépenses qui
n'aboutit pas à une vraie efficacité sur
le terrain mais aussi une incapacité à
décider parce que les décideurs sont
trop nombreux pour pouvoir se mettre
d'accord et et je crois que ce
millefeuille territorial est le résultat
de succession d'âge ou qui n'ont jamais
été réellement suivi de clarifications
nécessaires
aujourd'hui il faut décider je pense que
ce sera un sujet important pour l'avenir
de l'action publique en france
allez on va parler des dossiers
européens à commencer par ce plan de
relance de la commission européenne dont
on va voir les chiffres
est ce que pour vous ce plan de relance
il est à la hauteur des enjeux
moi je suis très sceptique sur la
manière dont ce plan de relance
se construit c'est à dire sur un emprunt
européen pour la première fois et c'est
vraiment un fait inédit il faut
reconnaître qu emmanuel macron a réussi
à emporter la décision sur ce point
pour la première fois la commission
européenne va emprunter de l'argent
jusque-là l'union européenne devait
équilibrer ses ressources
essentiellement la contribution des
états et ses dépenses elles ne pouvaient
pas aller sur les marchés
mais cet emprunt en réalité d'abord
finalement et les chiffres que vous
voyez là peuvent paraître impressionnant
mais en réalité son effet de levier est
relativement faible pour la france par
exemple c'est 38 milliards d'euros 38
milliards d'euros
quand on sait que le déficit public sur
cette seule année sera de 220 milliards
d'euros que le président de la
république nous a dit il y a quelques
jours que la france avait déjà mis 500
milliards d'euros sur la crise du corona
dieuze 37 milliards on le voit ça ne
produira pas sur plusieurs années en
plus un effet vraiment décisif et
surtout ça produit pour le coup un grand
nombre de problèmes et une
transformation de l'union européenne qui
d'un point de vue démocratique me paraît
poser un immense problème parce que si
nous empruntons ensemble sur les marchés
alors ça veut dire que nous nous lions
par une solidarité budgétaire qui est
évidemment renforcée et donc ça veut
dire que la commission européenne va
assumer
fatalement un contrôle budgétaire encore
renforcé sur les états européens ce qui
veut dire concrètement que certains
parlent sur la scène européenne de
moments hamiltonien du nom de hamilton
qui avait été le premier au 10ème siècle
à faire que les états américain
s'endette ensemble créant par là le
fédéralisme américain mais l'europe
n'est pas un état fédéral et moi je ne
crois pas au fédéralisme européen
je pense que le modèle européen n'est
pas le modèle américain et qu'il faut
respecter ce modèle démocratique il faut
respecter la souveraineté budgétaire des
états sinon on va produire encore plus
de 7 pour vous cette mutualisation des
dettes c'est une atteinte à la
souveraineté française par la
souveraineté des pays européens mais à
la souveraineté française
c'est effectivement de manière évidente
1 le pas nécessaire vers un nouveau
transfert de souveraineté sur le plan
budgétaire et et personne ne peut le
contester
sauf que personne ne le dit et que le
président de la république et son
gouvernement se garde bien d'expliquer
aux français quelles sont les
conséquences de ce choix qu'ils sont en
train de faire les conséquences ne sont
pas assumés en fait de cet emprunt
commun aujourd'hui on vend aux français
de gros chiffres
comme si l'argent allait tomber du ciel
on ne leur dit pas que cela un peu
des contreparties en termes de réformes
structurelles et moi je crois que nous
avons des réformes à faire mais je crois
que nous devons les décider nous mêmes
et que ce n'est pas à la commission
européenne de décider des réformes qui
doivent être faites en france on revient
à la question de la décentralisation la
subsidiarité c'est ça d'abord et puis je
crois aussi qu'on devrait affronter dès
maintenant les conséquences de cet
emprunt c'est à dire un remboursement
or aujourd'hui on va souscrire un
emprunt dont tout le monde sait que
l'union européenne n'a pas les moyens de
le rembourser
et personne ne dit comment il va être
remboursée est-ce qu'il faudra demain
créer un impôt européen
en tous les cas il faut dire la vérité
aux français il faut leur présenter le
scénario global et non pas seulement
l'idée que d'un seul coup 750 milliards
d'euros vont nous tomber du ciel
demain c'est pour nos enfants des dettes
à rembourser
c'est donc évidemment des ressources à
trouver et moi je crois que ce plan qui
s'appelle ironiquement le plan de la
future génération sera celui qui trahira
la future génération
si nous nous contentons de repousser sur
son dos les problèmes que nous n'avons
pas su régler aujourd'hui est ce que
l'union européenne n'a pas démontré son
inefficacité durant cette crise
sanitaire
ce serait faux de le de la juger d'une
manière aussi radicale évidemment au
début elle a été un peu tétanisé par la
crise parce que l'union européenne n'est
pas fait pour affronter les crises
ensuite elle s'est relativement
rapidement ajuster avec la souplesse
requise à ce qu'il fallait apporter de
réponse aux pays européens pour pour
traverser cette épidémie et pour faire
face à la crise économique qui se
présentait mais maintenant ce que
l'union européenne veut faire de mieux
pour préparer la relance c'est d'abord
de transformer sa doctrine
j'allais dire d'une manière générale
dans son rapport à la mondialisation
au fond ce que nous avons payées dans
cette crise ça n'est pas d'abord
l'incapacité de l'union européenne à
faire face à la crise sanitaire ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas sa compétence mais ce que
nous avons payé assez cher c'est la
naïveté de l'europe dans son rapport à
la mondialisation jusque là c'est le
fait que parce qu'au fond nous vivions
dans l'idée que il s'agissait de se
laisser faire dans une mondialisation
qui nous apporterait sans cesse les
meilleurs produits au moindre coût
finalement nous avons perdu notre
capacité de produire ce dont nous avons
besoin c'est ce que nous avons dit pour
notre part toute la campagne européenne
et nous l'avons vécu violemment dans
cette crise quand nous en avons été
réduits à quémander en chine des masques
pour nos infirmières pour nos médecins
quand les pays européens se sont
disputés entre eux les produits de
première nécessité qui arrivait
depuis les aéroports asiatiques alors on
voit très bien que au fond notre naïveté
dans la mondialisation nous a placés
dans une situation de très grande
dépendance de très grande fragilité
c'est ça qu'il faut essentiellement
alors emmanuel macron ainsi on dit de
parler de souveraineté européenne à la
raison de parler d'indépendance non la
souveraineté c'est la capacité de
décider et je pense que en europe
les états doivent garder cette capacité
de décider en revanche nous avons raison
de vouloir et nous l'avons défendu
encore une fois c'est le coeur de notre
projet est depuis le début de notre
mandat ne vouloir construire notre
reconstruire notre autonomie européenne
sur des sujets stratégiques
c'est la question de la santé mais c'est
aussi la question de l'alimentation
la france est en train de devenir
dépendantes du point de vue agricole ce
qui est d'une gravité inouïe du point de
vue y compris politiques parce que être
dépendant pour son alimentation ça veut
dire évidemment ne plus être
complètement saoul vin c'est vrai nous
avons besoin de reconstruire notre
autonomie sur le plan de l'industrie de
défense parce que la prochaine crise
elle sera pas forcément sanitaire elle
sera peut-être sécuritaire elle se
trouvera peut-être sur d'autres terrains
que nous ne connaissons pas encore et
oui là c'est vrai que ce que l'union
européenne peut faire de mieux y compris
pour la relance économique
c'est sortir de la naïveté par exemple
dans son rapport à la chine si
aujourd'hui vous mettez des milliards
d'euros sur un marché européen qui
continue d'importer des produits qu'il
ne sait pas faire
alors en réalité vous aller alimenter la
relance économique chinoise
ce qui compte c'est de réussir à
protéger notre marché en tous les cas à
exiger une réciprocité absolu de la part
de nos partenaires commerciaux et ça ce
serait une nouveauté absolue ce qui
compte c'est de faire en sorte que nous
appliquions les mêmes règles y compris
sociales et écologiques aux produits qui
arrivent sur notre territoire qu'à ce
que nous produisons nous mêmes et que
nous cessions d'organiser cette
concurrence déloyale qui pèsent sur nos
propres entreprises
je pense à ce transport routier
convenait tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
c'est écoeurant pour beaucoup de gens
qui travaillent en france de voir que
l'union européenne leur applique des
normes qu'elles n'appliquent pas à des
concurrents extra européens qui viennent
travailler chez nous évidemment que nous
ne pouvons qu'en être fragilisés est ce
que l'europe peut faire de mieux pour
servir la relance en france c'est
d'abord de changer ses règles et de
réussir à garantir une vraie efficacité
françois-xavier bellamy le parti
populaire européen qui est la droite un
européenne vous a désigné pour conduire
une réflexion sur la droite comment vous
allez faire pour trouver une ligne
commune d'une droite qui va de vous à
viktor orban
d'abord la première chose c'est que moi
je suis très heureux de cette mission
qui commence parce que je crois que la
droite a besoin d'une clarification
elle a besoin de mettre sur la table des
questions fondamentales et je crois que
c'est ce que c'est ce que nous allons
tenter de faire en france aussi bien que
sur la scène que sur la scène européenne
parce que parce que peut-être depuis
trop longtemps les familles politiques
de droite se sont finalement exonérer la
nécessité de penser les les grands
problèmes auxquels il fallait faire face
et et se sont installés dans le confort
d'une forme de deux répétitions et donc
oui il ya un vrai travail à faire pour
discuter tout simplement des questions
les plus importantes pour notre avenir
et sa déjà ne peut qu'être utile
et puis ensuite pour identifier ce qu'il
doit faire notre ligne commune et oui ce
sera forcément une discussion
compliquées mais en même temps je crois
que si on y regarde bien
nous devons puiser dans dans notre
héritage intellectuel de quoi à la fois
penser les défis de l'avenir avec une
exigence de renouvellement dans le
vocabulaire dans les solutions mais
aussi en assumant une vraie fidélité qui
peut être parfois à manquer une vraie
cohérence une vraie constance avec ce
qui doit définir je crois
l'identité politique de notre famille de
pensée pour qu'elle puisse servir
authentique aussi au niveau français est
ce que les riches et les républicains il
manque aussi une ligne claire il manque
aussi de la cohérence de la constance
oui on a eu l'occasion d'avoir une
journée de réflexion avec avec le comité
stratégique des républicains il ya
quelques jours et avec avec christian
jacob c'est un pas un pas en avant qui
va dans le bon sens on a besoin de ces
de ces temps de réflexion de fond on a
besoin de poser sur la table les débats
les plus les plus importants et pour
cause il clair chez les républicains et
pas d'unité dans la dans la campagne
européenne moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est que quand je suis entré
dans cette campagne vous savez moi je
n'étais pas jeu
je n'étais pas programmé pour pour pour
vivre cet engagement ça faisait pas
partie de mes plans et quand j'ai
commencé cette campagne tout le monde
m'a dit l'europe c'est le lieu de la
contradiction permanente sur l'europe la
droite dit tout et son contraire
eh bien c'était faux nous avons défendu
une vision très claire très précises
un programme très complet et nous
l'avons défendue avec une vraie unité au
sein de notre famille politique donc je
crois pas que on soit obligé de
constater des contradictions insolubles
mais je pense que oui il faut faire un
travail intellectuel un travail de fond
pour pouvoir dégager une ligne claire et
que les français ont besoin de cette
clarté pour faire confiance de nouveau à
notre famille politique
merci beaucoup merci français que vous
avez bel ami de l'un était avec nous
lundi deux invités à votre place
émission spéciale david cormand pour
europe écologie verts et brice hortefeux
pour les républicains en passe aussitôt
club des territoires